los muertos se cuentan por decenas en
arauca colombia después de choques entre
el ejército de liberación nacional y
disidencias de las farc esta caravana
por la paz en el municipio de tame salió
a la calle para pedir ayuda urgente
necesitamos presencia de las
organizaciones el pueblo tiene miedo
pero no nos vamos a resignar y no vamos
a permitir volver a revivir esa época de
dolor y de violencia arauca es un
departamento fronterizo con venezuela y
una ruta para economías ilícitas además
de también también se han visto
afectados los municipios de fortúl
saravena y arauquita ante esta situación
el presidente de colombia iván duque
lideró una reunión de emergencia y
desplazó al lugar al ministro de defensa
y dos batallones en rueda de prensa
culpó al gobierno venezolano en esa zona
limítrofe operan grupos armados ilegales
que también han estado en territorio
venezolano con tolerancia apoyo y
protección del régimen dictatorial sin
embargo los enfrentamientos en esa zona
son históricos en la primera década de
2000 las extintas farc y el eln entraron
en guerra ésta cesó en 2010 dejando 58
mil desplazados y más de 800 civiles
asesinados amplio detalles para france24
camilo gómez pozo presidente in the path
y que no es nueva no es de este año
por supuesto que ahí se alternan
entendimientos aparentes alianzas y
enfrentamientos según human rights watch
las disidencias y el ejército de
liberación nacional habrían roto su
alianza por la violencia en las
extorsiones del frente 10 también por el
manejo de la pandemia y después de que
el ejército de liberación nacional no se
implicasen los enfrentamientos entre el
frente 10 y el ejército venezolano en
marzo que causaron 5.000 desplazados del
municipio venezolano de apure